[Music]
who would benefit most from grounding
what are the most notable benefits
i've experienced a lot of personal
benefits reduction in inflammation seems
to be the big one right because the
inflammation is what leads to everything
else yes
okay the the most important thing
is if you have pain in your body you
have inflammation if you are grounded to
the earth
part grounded to the earth and stayed
there then it would resolve the
inflammation and you can't have
inflammation when you're grounded so
that's the
premise of grounding
inflammation is something new it's only
been around i mean the concept of
describing information came around 204
so it's only been around 18 years that's
unbelievable yeah in high school they
weren't talking about inflammation no no
um so i'm
did i am i getting the question totally
yeah so who would benefit most from from
earthing i mean anybody seems like
anyone but yeah anyone who has pain in
their body but most importantly women
because women are more sensitive uh to
the things in the environment maybe
because of children and whatever i'm not
sure but but they sense everything in
their environment and it uh
it affects their sympathetic nervous
system so
and the sympathetic effects fight or
flight in in very subtle ways and so
your body becomes filled with cortisol
which
dampens in
the parasympathetic and so on and and so
that creates anxiety irritability pain
and so on
so but
everybody is affected equally i think
but women are the ones who are
you put us this way 90 of the visits to
a practitioner for female
18 90 of all
nutraceuticals or pharmaceuticals are
female
men don't do anything no pain no gain
until you have your first heart attack
you don't take any of this seriously
yeah
right and so what we're doing right now
through a lot of our so-called solutions
we're actually creating more problems by
not addressing the root of our pain the
root of our illness the root of our dis
ease
and
what grounding what reconnecting with
the earth does it helps us create the
electrical charge
neutral charge in our body so that we
have the opportunity to heal yes yeah
it's a
it's about restoring the body to normal
in nature i mean
throughout all time we were naturally
grounded to the earth
and our bodies were always had a
negative charge so we have an immune
system that evolved that operated with
reactive oxygen species which are
electrically charged molecules
never an issue not a problem as long as
you're grounded
you know because you have excess free
electrons to mop up and prevent any
collateral damage from
the free radicals
but when you lose your
electron charge
and your body's full of cortisol your ph
is off which is another major electrical
and your
you know the radicals just start
damaging cell and so you end up with a
chain reaction of the immune system
trying to put out a fire that it itself
is creating because it doesn't know that
it's no longer grounded or doesn't have
the natural resources that it used to
have in nature
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free